I don't almost considered retiring at
the Sochi Olympics and in Russia and
things just didn't go the way I'd hoped
I wanted that medal before I made my
exit and so I was left with this sort of
like what next you know feeling and I
made my way to the next Olympics
um but I felt really fortunate you know
because in other sports after talking
with other athletes like I got to decide
you know I wasn't pulled in an office
and they're like look yeah it's over we
really liked it we're not fantastic yeah
yeah you're great and all but yeah but
or hurt yeah
you know and that can happen and so I
felt very fortunate that I got to decide
but it was very surreal you know I
remember taking this chair lift ride
actually got lost on the resort and the
sun's going down I'm going up the
chairlift my back's hurting my knees
swollen and I'm just like
I think it's time I think it's time and
I I kind of had a all it meant I had a
little cry on the chair and I was like
okay yeah